bonjour dames et cinéma les aujourd'hui
mme sacépé cazottes quelques techniques
d'arrosage
déjà arrosé plus tôt le matin très tôt
donc pour pas que le soleil fasse un
effet loupe sur la plante par rapport à
l'eau et sinon en fin de soirée
c'est beaucoup mieux pour la plante donc
il subira pas de nid de pourriture ni de
d'attac 17 par rapport à ça ni de choc
thermique aussi
donc selon le cycle de vie de la plante
donc si elle est beaucoup plus jeune a
planté les gens dont faudra l'emporter
du lot mais très très légère donc pour
papa pas l'abîmer déjà et pour pas créer
un effet de pourrissement aussi
chacun utilise le tuyau mêla rosa
traditionnel c'est juste tuyaux et le
pousse donc avec le pouce aux va avoir
faire une cuisine pour pas fait des
grosses gouttes et ça va pas créer de
flacq dans le massif
sinon on peut plier ici car c'est le
juger pour limiter la force du j'ai donc
donc repas animé la plante voilà donc
l'idéal ça se fait ça ce type de
pistolet l'a donc ici ou là un pistolet
à multi g1 on a plusieurs jets qui sont
dedans donc moi j'ai choisi le en pluie
fine
s'est installé leur boucher
le clap et les pistolets ici voilà
donc ici on a
un match hors d'elle voilà abuse ils
sont las du bon boulot et ici c'est les
plantes qu'on a planté là c'est les
plantes à massifs mais ici par exemple
ici le bon bout l'un on va la rosée plus
au pied de la plante donc la pénétration
ono ça sera mieux et pour le feuillage
aussi ça ça ça va protéger de données
retenues comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure
la chandelle et dans un endroit où il a
que l'abe on peut la rose est juste
collé
l'arrosage permet aussi de nettoyer la
plante siens d'enlever les faux amis de
la poussière et donc c'est certain mais
souvent ça s'appelle donc
ça va rafraîchir la plante aussi
déjà bien se renseigner sur la planche
si c'est une plante qui demande beaucoup
d'eau ben faut apporter de l'eau et si
c'est une plante qui demandent pas
beaucoup d'eux apporter de l'eau
justement est pas trop parce que
certains tentent ne
pourrisse si on a un apport trop eu deux
points importants
voilà ici sur les pétales mais faudra
vraiment éviter d'arroser quand il ya
combien cela laisse donc ça va faire un
effet loupe et ça va brûler la plante
pleindoux siens et être vraiment prudent
voilà surtout pas rose et il ya un gros
l'enseignement
plutôt arrosée au collet de la plante
d'ici là
au garde bien de pas de talent et de
composer déjà ici par exemple récent le
basique à base de terre végétale donc
pour pouvoir vraiment savoir si on a
fait un bon arrosage d'autres l'adieu la
technique du coup semaine je vais mettre
le doigt où le pousse à l'intérieur
du massif au savoir si l'on a vraiment
bien pénétré dedans donc ici je vois que
l'on a bien pénétré donc en dessous il
est vraiment nous dira donc sur macif là
j'ai fait un bon arrosage n'hésitez pas
à toucher la plante a touché la terre à
savoir si on a bien arrosé ou pas donc
il faut pas hésiter à se salir les mains
en fait c'est comme ça qu'on développe
sa main bien voilà c'est en touchant les
plantes et surtout la terre ici